(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Nessa aula, nós vamos falar sobre o termo
indisponibilidade, que aparece em algumas matrículas.
Indisponibilidade é uma restrição realizada pelo poder judiciário
para que o proprietário não possa dispor de
seu imóvel.
Então, o proprietário fica impedido de vender seu
imóvel de forma tradicional.
Só que essa indisponibilidade, ela não alcança a
venda forçada, alienação forçada.
E o leilão judicial, ele é uma venda
forçada, ele é uma alienação forçada.
Por quê?
Porque o leilão judicial, ele acontece por ordem
de um juiz.
Ele nada tem a ver com a vontade
do proprietário daquele imóvel de levar o seu
imóvel a leilão.
Então, a indisponibilidade não impossibilita que um leilão
judicial ocorra, porque o leilão judicial é uma
venda forçada, que decorre de uma ordem do
poder judiciário, de um juiz, e o leilão
vai acontecer normalmente.
Um imóvel, ele pode ter uma ou várias
indisponibilidades.
Nada proíbe que aquele proprietário, ele seja réu
em 10, 20 processos.
E nesses processos, os juízes determinem a indisponibilidade
dos bens desse réu, que é o proprietário
do imóvel.
Por que a indisponibilidade existe?
Vamos supor que eu estou sendo processada e
alguém está cobrando um valor X de mim.
Eu tenho que pagar esse valor X para
alguém.
É isso que essa pessoa quer através de
um processo judicial.
O juiz, no decorrer do processo, ele vai
entendendo que realmente aquela pessoa que está me
cobrando judicialmente tem direito a receber aquele valor.
Só que existe uma grande chance de eu
dilapidar o meu patrimônio durante aquele processo.
Isso é, eu estou sendo processada, eu sei
que no final daquele processo eu vou perder
um valor, e eu começo a vender tudo
que eu tenho de bem para não pagar
nada naquele processo.
Porque vai ser o famoso caso daquela pessoa
que ganhou e não levou.
Quem está me processando vai ganhar, mas pode
não levar porque eu me desfiz de todo
o meu patrimônio.
Então o que o juiz faz?
Ele determina a indisponibilidade do meu patrimônio.
Se eu tiver um bem imóvel, o juiz
pode determinar a indisponibilidade do meu bem imóvel.
E aquele meu bem vai ficar reescrito e
eu não consigo vender de forma tradicional.
Mas nada impede que o juiz, no final
daquele processo, fale que realmente eu devo pagar
uma quantia para outra pessoa e que aquele
meu bem que estava indisponível vai ser penhorado
para que possa ocorrer o leilão judicial.
Penhora a gente já estudou aqui no curso,
então vocês já sabem como é que funciona.
Para um bem ser leiloado, primeiro ele tem
que ser penhorado.
A gente já falou isso na aula específica
aqui sobre penhora.
Então qual é a consequência de existir indisponibilidade
na matrícula de um imóvel?
A arrematação acontece normalmente, porque a indisponibilidade não
afeta uma venda forçada.
O leilão judicial é uma venda forçada.
E depois da arrematação, a indisponibilidade será cancelada
pelo juiz que ordenou o leilão ou caso
ele entenda que aquela indisponibilidade deve ser cancelada
por cada juiz que determinou cada indisponibilidade, você
vai ter que fazer da mesma forma que
a gente já falou na aula de penhora.
Você vai ter que pedir para cada juiz
que determinou a indisponibilidade determinar o cancelamento daquela
indisponibilidade.
E isso é bem tranquilo, a gente acabou
de ver aqui que a indisponibilidade ela serve
para que o proprietário, ele não venda o
seu imóvel de forma tradicional, por sua livre
e espontânea vontade.
Ele não vai poder vender esse imóvel pela
vontade dele pura e simplesmente.
Agora o judiciário, ele pode vender.
Se um juiz determinar um leilão, as indisponibilidades
que existem naquela matrícula vão ser canceladas após
o leilão.